und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend vorgestern erst montag betrat eine
gestresst wirkende annegret kramp
karrenbauer eine bühne in berlin als
vorsitzende der cdu und verließ sie nur
augenblicke später als figur des
übergangs das brachte er einiges
durcheinander aber ein paar punkte
schienen festzustehen erstens sie wird
den übergang steuern
zweitens erst wird die kanzlerkandidatur
geklärt dann der parteivorsitz drittens
beides wird dieselbe person sein
viertens alles hat zeit bis ende des
jahres vorsitz und kannst du diese
person ist klar geblieben als forderung
völlig unklar allerdings wie das gehen
soll
alles andere steht unter fragezeichen
oben dran die packendste frage von allen
wehrmacht mathis feldhoff über den stand
der dinge
es ist keine überraschung was jens spahn
heute mitzuteilen hat es ist eine
überraschung dass er es heute mitteilt
knapp 48 stunden nach dem rückzieher der
cdu parteivorsitzenden wirft jens spahn
seinen hut in den ring um die
kanzlerkandidatur und den parteivorsitz
seiner partei habe immer gesagt das habe
ich denke ich auch dokumentiert in den
letzten eineinhalb zwei jahren dass ich
bereit bin verantwortung zu übernehmen
in welcher konstellation das aber
geschieht darüber reden wir jetzt eben
in den nächsten tagen sparen vermeidet
den satz ich kandidiere seine absicht
haben seine konkurrenten auch so
verstanden
friedrich merz etwa heute abend melden
die agenturen aus seinem umfeld er sei
zur kandidatur entschlossen gestern
abend klang noch vorsichtig weiß er doch
dass wenn es nicht klappt er trotzdem
gern dabei wäre wenn in der cdu
demnächst die macht verteilt
es gibt immer einen tag danach
auch hier gibt es einen tag danach und
an dem tag danach müssen alle
beteiligten in der lage sein sich ins
auge zu schauen und vernünftig
miteinander den weg zu gehen den wir
gemeinsam nur auf
einer alleine wird das nicht schaffen
der tag danach es klingt wie eine
mahnung an sich selbst märz hat viele
sympathien in der cdu eingebüßt nach
seiner harten kritik an der kanzlerin
vor drei monaten jetzt will er nicht
ungeduldig werden
im konrad-adenauer-haus werden nun
mögliche szenarien geprüft ein
sonderparteitag vielleicht bisher
bestätigt man aber nur gespräche der
vorsitzenden mit allen bewerbern in der
nächsten woche das sich kramp
karrenbauer auch mit csu-chef söder
treffen könnte etwa am rande der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz dementiert
die cdu-chefin heute äußerst schwach ich
bin mir ganz sicher dass markus söder
als bayerischer ministerpräsident auch
an der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
teilnehmen wird das werde ich auch tun
und die wird man sagen ich bin bei der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz als
verteidigungsministerin sehr sehr gut
ausgelastet so dass für was anderes
keine zeit bleiben denn jetzt steigt der
druck auf den mann der sich bisher nicht
zu seinen ambitionen äußert armin
laschet ministerpräsident und cdu chef
in nrw zögert noch öffentliche
erklärungen gibt es heute nicht
die cdu erwartet jetzt eine gütliche
einigung etwas was die kontrahenten wohl
verstanden haben ich finde wir müssen
uns doch alle mal schaffen sowohl wir
wie sie das erst mal alles vielleicht
ein paar tage dauern darf
damit man einfach in ruhe die dinge
besprechen kann das vorpreschen der
kandidaten zeigt die noch vorsitzende
bestimmt immer weniger in der cdu jetzt
nicht mal mehr den zeitplan
da als es interessant dass die spd heute
einen bremsklotz in den zeitplan
geworfen hat einen kanzlerwechsel wird
sie nicht mittragen sagte der spd
generalsekretär
sie seien mit merkel in die groko
gegangen und gehen mit ihr auch wieder
raus theo verfolgt das für uns in berlin
heißt das jetzt garantiert die spd
kanzlerin merkel den job naja es
entbehrt jedenfalls nicht einer gewissen
ironie dass die spd den arbeitsvertrag
der kanzlerin quasi gegen drängler aus
den eigenen unionsreihen sicherheit auf
die frage aber ist was das für den neuen
cdu parteivorsitzende und unions
kanzlerkandidaten bedeutet wenn der zwar
einerseits jetzt schon viel früher als
geplant gewählt wird dann aber für fast
anderthalb jahre dasselbe problem hat
dass auch frau kramp karrenbauer hatte
dass es da noch lange zeit eine
kanzlerin gibt die viele der fäden in
der hand hält und die ja übrigens ab
juli auch noch die deutscher
eu-präsidentschaft innehat und damit
politisch alles überstrahlen dürfte also
keine beneidenswerte wartestellung für
jeden kandidaten die kandidaten für
diese wartestellung das sind ja mal zwei
vertraute namen aus dem schaulaufen im
letzten jahr sind jens spahn und
friedrich merz und dann gibt es einen
neuen namen nämlich armin laschet den
ministerpräsidenten von nordrhein
westfalen die bescheidwisser in berlin
in räumen die wenn sie so zusammen
stehen die größten chancen ein
um ehrlich zu sein die berühmten
bescheidwisser von berlin die sind in
solchen zeiten auch gerne mal vor allem
wanderer nebel von vielen beobachtern
werden allerdings armin laschet die
besseren chancen zugeschrieben
nicht nur weil er den größten
landesverband hat sondern vor allem weil
er die merkel-cdu repräsentiert und die
steht ja noch immer für den größeren
teil der partei gleichzeitig aber muss
man sagen hat friedrich merz das größte
potenzial cdu säle zu füllen und zu
begeistern und aktuell scheint mir muss
ich sagen jede prognose eher töricht nun
hat ja ak erklärt dass erst über die
kanzlerkandidatur entschieden wird und
dann über den vorsitz kanzlerkandidatur
wird mit der csu entschieden
vorsitzender der cdu natürlich ohne die
csu wie wie soll das überhaupt zusammen
gehen also sehr präzise beschreibung es
kann insgesamt einfach nicht so laufen
wie das frau kramp karrenbauer
angekündigt hat und zwar mindestens aus
zwei gründen erstens wenn
kanzlerkandidatur und cdu parteivorsitz
zwingend an eine person gehen sollen
dann heißt das doch im umkehrschluss
dass kein csu vertreter die möglichkeit
hätte überhaupt kanzlerkandidat zu
werden oder ist hieße zweitens dass die
csu ein mitspracherecht beim cdu-vorsitz
hätte denn natürlich kann die csu als
teil der union auch den künftigen
kanzlerkandidaten mitbestimmen also das
passt hinten und vorne nicht zusammen
stimmt mal der blöde spruch von den alle
klarheiten beseitigt dankeschön
t um die afg ist jedenfalls stolz darauf
wie gründlich sie mit ihrem erfurter
hütchen trick die politische landschaft
aufmischt sie zwingt der cdu eine
debatte auf für die die noch keine
haltung findet keine einheitliche
jedenfalls umgang mit ganz rechts mit
einer partei in der sich aus sicht der
mainstream cdu konservative demokraten
gender debatten genervte eu skeptiker
und mehr zusammenfinden mit rassisten
und neu faschisten die antwort auf diese
herausforderung fällt in ost und west
verschiedenen aus auch weil die afg in
ost bundesländern wahlerfolge hat wie es
schwer machen an ihr noch vorbei zu
kommen
eindrücke von der basis da wie dort von
jahre hoffnung
seit heute ist stefan effenberger
mitglied des cdu ortsverbands magdeburg
olvenstedt
davor war er bei einem anderen
ortsverband der stadt aber diese stelle
den willen der basis mehr in den
vordergrund sagt er in seinen augen
beinhaltet das vor allem soziale werte
und darum gehe es nicht nur um die cdu
in sachsen anhalt ist nicht nur ein
verein der werte union oder
rechtskonservativen und man gibt hier
auch ganz viele sozial und liberale
werte in der cdu vertreten sehen wollten
und die haben mit diesen zirkel leuten
vom rechten rand überhaupt nichts zu tun
sondern
wir sind ganz klar in der mitte die sind
etwas ruhig zurzeit oder waren zu ruhig
und die müssen vielleicht mutiger werden
das ist wirklich richtig so viele die
sagen der zentrale punkt
die sind in den letzten monaten viel zu
ruhig gewesen und die jene meinung die
in extremer über die außenseiter ideen
sind die herren geschrieben und haben
sich nach vorne aber doch irgendwann mit
den außenseitern mit dem extremen klare
abgrenzung zu den linken und der auf de
ist der konsens genau so dass man mit
ihnen keine koalition eingehen dürfen
gleichzeitig gilt auf kommunaler ebene
könne man eine zusammenarbeit nicht
vermeiden ins einem zebrastreifen geht
der wird der bauantrag von der ft und er
ist an der stelle richtig da muss
natürlich auch der cdu gucken dass
dieser zebrastreifen dahin kommt die
kleinigkeiten beim alljährlichen
grünkohlessen des nordrhein
westfälischen cdu ortsverbands
bochum-weitmar sieht man das ganz anders
richtung geben nichts weder kommunalwahl
auf landesebene noch bundesebene linke
und die sind für unsere für die
parteimitglieder ist nach wie vor klar
die cdu ist eine partei der mitte
für mich steht für die soziale
marktwirtschaft also einen ausgleich der
interessen von arbeitnehmern aber eben
auch arbeitgebern vor allen dingen aus
dem mittel stünden die meisten
arbeitnehmer in deutschland arbeiten im
mittelstand im handwerk in den
mittelständischen betrieben in den
dienstleistungsgewerbe das sind die
bürger auf die wir auch unser augenmerk
haben müssen da müssen wir aufpassen
dass diejenige nach links abdriften die
politische mitte ist eigentlich die
gruppierung die verbinden kann die
brücken bauen kann und nichtig waltet
das stelle ich mir untermiete form dass
man offen ist dass man zuhört dass man
respekt zeigt dass man niemanden
diffamiert und dass man auch ehrlich ist
und keine spielchen spielt das ist die
cdu
das hoffe ich das hoffe ich
dass die cdu brücken bauen kann und
sollte sieht auch stefan effenberger in
sachsen anhalt so an einer sache müsste
man jetzt allerdings besonders arbeiten
ich glaube dass kommunikation ein punkt
den wir vernachlässigt und der neu
aufgelegte muss wir müssen miteinander
reden das ist manchmal nicht einfach
aber es muss gemacht werden und das kam
zu kurz dass carmen definitiv zu kurz
2021 finden in sachsen-anhalt
landtagswahl statt noch zeit also um
miteinander zu reden
diese zukunft mag ein bisschen unklar
seien aber noch produziert die große
koalition kabinettsbeschlüssen
pflegebedürftige und ihre angehörigen
sollen mehr unterstützung erhalten
die bundesregierung hat einen
gesetzentwurf beschlossen um die
bedingungen für intensivpflege und
medizinische reha zu hause einfacher und
besser zu machen
derzeit werden in deutschland fast 1,8
millionen menschen zu hause gepflegt
gesundheitsminister sparen prüft zudem
vorschläge mit denen pflegeleistungen
klarer strukturiert und besser
finanziert werden sollen
ziel ist auch eine entlastung der 2,5
millionen pflegenden angehörigen in der
abhöraffäre um die schweizer crypto ag
und die geheimdienste bnd und fordern
parlamentarier in deutschland und der
schweiz aufklärung es sei ungeheuerlich
dass offenbar langfristig freund und
feind ausgespäht worden sei sagte der
fdp-fraktionsvize thome das
bundeskanzleramt müsse umgehend sein
schweigen brechen aufgedeckt hatten die
abhöraffäre das zdf das schweizer
fernsehen und die washington post den
recherchen zufolge hatte bnd und sie
jahrzehntelang mit manipulierter
kommunikation zahlreichen staaten
ausspioniert dabei auch
menschenrechtsverletzungen aufgedeckt
ohne dass deutschland oder die usa
handelten im rennen um die us
präsidentschaftskandidatur der
demokraten hat der ehemalige
vizepräsident joe biden eine zweite
niederlage erlitten
bei den vorwahlen im us-bundesstaat new
hampshire landete er nur auf platz fünf
die meisten stimmen sammeln konnte den
links berichtete senator bernie sanders
gefolgt vom früheren bürgermeister peter
ditsch den dritten platz sicherte sich
überraschend die bisher weniger bekannte
senatorin
die sollte man sich merken
es hat sich herumgesprochen wie wichtig
ist für deutschland sei die super
schnelle mobilfunktechnik 5g einzuführen
daran hängen anwendungen die über die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit ganzer industrien
entscheiden
das problem ist dass 5g eine technik ist
bei der ein chinesischer konzern huawei
führendes viele auch im bundestag warnen
davor einem solchen unternehmen
ausgerechnet kommunikation anzuvertrauen
von außen drohen die usa mit sanktionen
und dem entzug von vertrauen und
geheimdienst erkenntnis wenn deutschland
sich in die hände von guave gibt die
bundesregierung scheut sich aber dem
mächtigen china eine blockade vor den
latz zu knallen
thomas reichert über eine ohnehin schon
schwierige lage und dann hat er auch
noch erfahren dass die deutsche cyber
abwehr höchstens sehr bedingt
einsatzbereit ist
merkel sorge vor chinas rache muss sehr
groß sein sonst hätte es nicht so lange
gedauert bis die union sich auf ein
papier einig zum 5g ausbau und vor allem
auf einen kompromiss zur frage wie
umgehen mit dem chinesischen konzern
wir wissen dass die chinesen sehr
sensibel reagieren wenn es um ihre
lieblings firma huawei geht und da war
schon sehr viel sorge und die ist auch
immer noch vorhanden ausrichtung des
kanzleramt auch die möglichen
konsequenzen eines handelskrieges wenn
wir eben gewisse chinesische ausrüster
im endeffekt ausschließen würden die
union will feuerwehr deshalb nicht per
se ausschließen stattdessen sollen
höchste sicherheitsanforderungen gelten
kontrolliert von den zuständigen
bundesbehörden
die frage ist nur wie gut sind die
behörden auf diese sicherheitsprüfungen
vorbereitet dem zdf liegt exklusiv die
antwort der bundesregierung auf eine
anfrage der linkspartei vor
darin räumt die regierung ein dass sie
jede vierte stelle für it
sicherheitsexperten nicht besetzt hat
ausgerechnet im für cyber abwehr
zuständigen innenministerium ist es
sogar jede dritte stelle
ich hatte natürlich schon die vermutung
dass man das thema nicht ausreichend
würde ich deswegen habe ich die frage
gestellt dass die lage so katastrophales
das hatte ich mir nicht ausmalen können
gravierende lücken bei its sicherheit
und cyber abwehr
dabei weiß die regierung durchaus und
die gefahren die bei einer beteiligung
von frauen in einem geheimen dokument
warnt das auswärtige amt nach druck aus
washington vor dem chinesischen konzern
zitat ende 2009 10 wurde uns von us
seite den nachrichtendienstliche
informationen weiter gegeben denen
zufolge vor wir nachweislich mit
chinesischen sicherheitsbehörden
zusammen arbeite das sei die smoking gun
der entscheidende beweis gegen quasi das
größte risiko besteht darin dass ein
unternehmen ist das stark eingebettetes
in den chinesischen kontext der
geprägtes von steuerung von
einflussnahmen von möglichkeiten des
durch chris des sicherheitsapparates auf
alle unternehmen tatsächlich zeigten zdf
recherchen schon vor monaten wie eng die
zusammenarbeit mit china
staatssicherheit tatsächlich ist hier
besiegelt der ehemalige deutschland chef
von vw links im bild den aufbau eines
überwachungs labors
der partner china stasi der ort wo die
uigurische minderheit brutal überwacht
und unterdrückt wird
vorbei sagt die partei sei ihre neue
armee kann man so einem konzern die
infrastruktur der zukunft anvertrauen
wenn union und spd pochen sie auf
scharfe regeln
es ist klar für einen hersteller aus
einem nicht demokratischen land wird es
deutlich schwerer werden so eine solche
anforderung zu erfüllen durch ein
kompletter ausschluss cover ist das wäre
die machtprobe mit peking die kaum einer
wagt auch nicht angela merkel
es kommen wieder bedrückende bilder und
nachrichten aus dem nordwesten syriens
der provinz idlib letzte zuflucht
unterschiedlichster gruppen die einmal
glaubten sie könnten präsident assad mit
waffengewalt aus dem land jagen
diese hoffnung gibt es längst nicht mehr
assad regiert den allergrößten teil
syriens mit hilfe aus iran und die
rückendeckung aus moskau
erdogan will nicht dulden dass assad das
grenzgebiet zur türkei beherrscht und
die millionen syrischen flüchtlinge
zwingt in der türkei zu bleiben diese
konfrontation kann jederzeit aus dem
syrischen bürgerkrieg einen offenen
internationalen konflikt machen mit
russland und dem nato-land türkei als
kriegsgegner jörg brase berichtet
die botschaft dieser bilder ist
eindeutig und ist gerichtet an die
syrische regierung in damaskus
das droht euch wenn ihr es noch mal wagt
uns anzugreifen
die türkei wird in syrien mit den waffen
verlegt täglich noch mehr truppen panzer
artillerie munition aufrüsten entlang
einer waffenstillstandslinie die längst
keine mehr ist
sollte einer unserer soldaten in den
beobachtungsposten oder anderswo auch
nur die kleinste verletzungen
davontragen so erkläre ich hier und
jetzt werden wir gegen die syrischen
regierungstruppen zurückschlagen und
zwar überall auch jenseits der linien
die in sotchi abkommen vereinbart wurden
im september 2018 hatten russland und
die türkei in sotschi eine
demilitarisierte zone um idlib
ausgehandelt das von russland
unterstützte assad-regime sollte nicht
mehr angreifen die türkei die rebellen
der opposition entwaffnen
dieses abkommen ist heute nur noch
makulatur es gibt ganz sicher die gefahr
für einen offenen krieg zwischen der
türkei und syrien vor allem nachdem
präsident erdogan heute die
einsatzregeln des abkommens aufgekündigt
hat vergeltung für tote türkische
soldaten egal wo in syrien das ist neu
14 türkische militärs starben innerhalb
einer woche bei raketenangriffen
syrischer kräfte auf türkische
beobachtungsposten von der türkei
unterstützte rebellen schossen gestern
einen syrischen hubschrauber ab statt
sie zu entwaffnen musste die türkei
weiter us feindliche terroristen auf
kritisiert moskau auch das sei ein bruch
des abkommens von sotschi
die syrische offensive sei daher
gerechtfertigt russland und die türkei
liegen in syrien über kreuz
einerseits haben wir die massive
stationierung türkischer truppen in
idlib und der verbündeten
oppositionskräfte die bereits vor ort
sind
auf der anderen seite die assad
regierung die von russland unterstützt
wird ich sehe eine große gefahr dass
dieser konflikt eskaliert der plan der
türkei den syrischen präsidenten zu
stürzen ist nicht aufgegangen erdogans
truppen aber stehen auf us territorium
der versucht nun mit seinen angriffen
auf türkische posten zu erreichen dass
die türkei aus seinem land ab zieht es
droht ein offener krieg hunderttausende
fliehen vor den kämpfen aus der region
idleb eigentlich will ankara verhindern
dass noch mehr syrische flüchtlinge über
die grenze kommen doch auch dieser plan
droht nun zu scheitern
deutsche katholiken staaten in letzter
zeit auf die dschungel des amazonas als
könnte von dort r lösungen kommen von
den fesseln des zölibats von dogmen die
frauen ausgrenzen
weil die prekäre lage der kleinen
abgelegenen gemeinden dort ein lockern
der regeln lebenswichtig macht heute hat
der papst aus südamerika dazu einen
langen text geschrieben aber nicht das
von manchen in deutschland erhofft
der papst stellt darin weder eine
lockerung des zölibats in aussicht noch
ein weiheamt für frauen
die katholische frauengemeinschaft in
deutschland ist sehr enttäuscht das
papst schreiben sei ein herber schlag
für alle frauen die auf ein starkes
signal zur gleichberechtigung in der
katholischen kirche gehofft hatten
wut und traurigkeit spricht auch aus
einer reaktion der reformbewegung maria
2.0
es spielt keine weiterentwicklung leben
es wird eine verwaltung geben eine
bewahrung dessen was seit 2000 jahren
ist und ich wusste im moment nicht wie
sich kirche jetzt weiterentwickeln
sollte und damit ist letztendlich die
türe selbst bei diesem papst der ja für
ihre form durchaus steht ist definitiv
zu und ich weiß nicht mit welchen
argumenten wir jetzt noch kämpfen
sollten oder allen uns einsetzen sollten
dass ich da noch mal was bewegen kann
außer der letzten möglichkeit die wir
haben wir frauen zu sagen ohne uns der
globale marktplatz im internet führt
auch zum müllbergen von zurückgesandten
oder nicht verkauften artikeln weniger
abfall und mehr recycling das will die
bundesregierung mit dem neuen
kreislaufwirtschaftsgesetz erreichen
frank bethmann was sagen die unternehmen
die händler zu diesen staatlichen
vorgaben
naja die einzelnen halten kommen ja erst
noch deswegen reagierten die meisten
heute zunächst zurückhaltend die bundes
regierung will die unternehmen vor allem
dazu zwingen dass sie deutlich besser
dokumentieren was sie mit den nicht
verkauften artikel machen zb mit den
vielen zurückgesendeten produkten jedes
sechste paket in deutschland geht
inzwischen retour und 20 millionen
dieser rückläufer wandern direkt auf den
müll
das problem viele dieser häufig mode
artikel sind so billig dass die
lagerkosten auf den warenwert
übersteigen und eine entsorgung billiger
ist selbst das verschenken rechnet sich
in vielen fällen nicht sagen die händler
weil auf den wert der gespendeten waren
mehrwertsteuer erhoben wird
genau das kritisieren die unternehmen
dann auch warum wird nicht einfach die
mehrwertsteuer darauf abgeschafft geht
nichts sagt der bundesfinanzminister
weil das eu richtlinien widersprechen
und betrügereien erleichtern würde
im prinzip verschwendung beizukommen ist
in der praxis also gar nicht so einfach
und fängt im übrigen jahr bei uns
verbrauchern an wenn wir gezielter
bestellen geht auch weniger zurück gar
nicht zurück geht es in diesen tagen
beim dax über 120 zähler kann das
kursbarometer weiter zulegen auf
mittlerweile 13.750 punkte das ist der
höchste stand auf dem das kursbarometer
jemals schloss und dann schauen wir auf
morgen vielen dank frank die deutsche
film- und fernsehwelt trauert um den
preisgekrönten filmemacher joseph
vilsmaier der gestern im alter von 81
jahren in münchen gestorben ist
fast 50 jahre lang prägte er als
kameramann und regisseur die deutsche
filmlandschaft mit werken zwischen
sensibler wahrhaftigkeit und wohligen
klischees wie herbstmilch oder dem musik
für den comedian harmonists
dem meßmer drama nanga parbat trotz des
internationalen erfolgs blieb vilsmaier
seiner heimat bayern immer verbunden
flughafen freuen egal gehe irgendwohin
im franziskaner oder es weißwürste und
leberkäs und da bin ich wieder zu hause
und da fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom
lotto am mittwoch sie lauten diesmal wie
immer ohne gewähr
210 24 31 41 49 superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text aus china immer noch dem land mit
98 prozent der korona virus fälle wurden
heute weitere 2000 erkrankungen gemeldet
und 97 weitere tote gewachsen sind heute
aber vor allem die zweifel an den
amtlichen angaben der chinesischen
behörden die sind nämlich dazu
übergegangen infizierte nur dann noch in
die statistik aufzunehmen wenn sie
symptome zeigen das drückt die zahlen
künstlich nach unten und verstößt gegen
regeln der weltgesundheitsorganisation
dann gibt es eine vorsichtig positive
nachricht vom weltweiten wettlauf um
eine impfung gegen den virus sie kommt
aus deutschland
sie hat in amerika an hi viren geforscht
und in deutschland die einzige
impfstudie gegen ebola geleitet nun also
das neue corona virus professor marilyn
ag und ihr team an der uniklinik hamburg
arbeiten an einem impfstoff weltweit
stehen forscher unter druck die zahl der
infizierten steigt unaufhörlich zeit
viel zeit aber ist das was die
wissenschaftler brauchen
man kann diese winzigen stoff konstrukte
relativ schnell generieren im labor aber
dann
es ist ja ganz wichtig dass die noch
qualitätsgesichert werden dass es noch
tests gibt in tieren über die
wirksamkeit ob die überhaupt antikörper
induzieren und diese experimente oder
diese versuche die brauchen einfach zeit
es sieht so harmlos aus und ist doch
lebensgefährlich das neue corona virus
das die whu nun saß tv2 nennt
über 1100 tote gibt es bereits und die
experten wissen noch immer viel zu wenig
wir wissen nicht wie der weitere verlauf
der epidemie sein wird wird das jetzt
sich etablieren und kontinuierlich
präsent sein wird es saisonal wie die
grippe bekommen oder wird es nie wieder
kommen das wissen wir nicht klar ist das
risiko ist global und macht nicht vor
ländergrenzen halt internationale
experten berieten sich bis heute abend
bei der weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
unter ihnen auch professor christian
drosten er sagt das neue corona virus
könne zu einer pandemie also einer
kontinent übergreifenden infektion
werden allerdings es ist im wesentlichen
hier eine erkältungswelle die auf uns
zurollt die aber leider für einige
patienten da sind gerade ältere grund
erkrankte patienten mit der gefahr
einhergeht einer verschlechterung einer
verschlimmerung des klinischen bildes
mit hochdruck wird daher international
nach einem impfstoff geforscht wie auch
hier bei der firma covec schon in vier
monaten hoffen die tübinger
wissenschaftler einen wirkstoff
entwickelt zu haben doch auch der muss
dann erst durch klinische studien gehen
an menschen getestet werden
die bedrohung jetzt hat aber zumindest
ein gutes weltweit haben sich forscher
besser vernetzt jenseits von ideologien
das wurde immer bemängelt dass das dass
jeder versiegt am impfstoff entwickelt
hat natürlich verfolgt man
unterschiedliche ansätze informationen
von dem virus hat das ist das was alle
brauche die entwicklung eines
impfstoffes ist also wahrscheinlich auch
wenn er für die akute krise zu spät
kommt es bleibt ein wettlauf mit der
zeit
schön dass die welt in dieser sache mal
zusammen besteht wir empfehlen ihnen den
blick auf die welt den ihnen das
auslandsjournal gleich anbietet und sind
dann morgen wieder hier bis dann gestern
abend
[Musik]
im dom liebe zuschauer morgen schon
wieder neuen regen und sogar schnee ein
neues tief von westen zieht auf hier
liegt dieses regengebiet irland und
großbritannien wird sehr schnell weiter
ziehen überquert uns mit regen aber eben
auch mit schnee in den mittelgebirgen
und dahinter wird es dann aus dem
südwesten milder werden haben wir morgen
schon 15 grad in frankreich die werber
wahrscheinlich bei uns dann im südwesten
mindestens am sonntag auch erreichen
ansonsten bleibt eben in mitteleuropa
morgen noch ein bisschen kühler unter
diesen regen und schnee wollten heute
nacht klart es gebietsweise auf es gibt
kaum noch schauer es wird gefährlich
glatt minus 2 bis minus fünf grad meist
die temperaturen und das nicht mehr ganz
so windig morgen dreht der wind dann auf
süden und wir haben dann neuen regen
hier im westen zu erwarten schon am
vormittag mit schnee oberhalb von 3 400
meter in den mittelgebirgen nach osten
hin
da ist es noch sonnig aber zum
nachmittag hin wird es auch dort stärker
bewölkt es fängt an zu regnen in den
mittelgebirgen schneit es immer noch
aber im westen lockert auf mit
regenschauern da kommt ja schon ein
bisschen die mildere luft an und wir
haben teilweise eben diesem stürmischen
wind aus süden an den küsten und über
den mittelgebirgen die temperaturen
erreichen dann meist vier bis sieben im
westen im oberrhein bis zu zehn grad und
dann kommt sozusagen das wochenende
langsam vor allen dingen am samstag und
sonntag wird es im norden immer wieder
regnen im süden scheint die sonne aber
schauen sie am sonntag hier im südwesten
die temperaturen an
aber dazu gibt sturm an der küste auch
okay ich wünschen noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut